good afternoon everyone thank you all
for coming it's a beautiful week in
Pittsburgh with fresh faces new students
enormous optimism and great energy we
also have some exciting things to
announce and I want to give my
appreciation to all of you for taking
the time from your busy schedules to be
here Gordon wolf thank you so much for
coming from Harrisburg Congressman Mike
Doyle allegheny county executive bill
Fitzgerald rich Fitzgerald Bill Peduto
where we will join us shortly chairman
of the board of Carnegie Mellon
University Jim roar we have former
president of Carnegie Mellon University
Jerry Cohen CEO of u.s. steel Mario
Longhi many members of the Carnegie
Mellon Board of Trustees members members
of the senior leadership team Dean's
faculty members students thank you all
very much for coming here today today we
are here to announce a major gift to
Carnegie Mellon University at 35 million
dollar gift from Tata Consultancy
Services which is a global IT company
headquartered in Mumbai in India but
which operates in 46 countries around
the world whose clients include nearly
half of the top 100 fortune companies in
the world we are particularly pleased
that Tata Consultancy Services has
chosen Carnegie Mellon University as its
first major and largest university
partner as they do pioneering work at
the cutting edge of tech
knology essentially around the world
it's a historic moment for a variety of
reasons it's the largest gift from a
corporation from largest corporate gift
in the history of Carnegie Mellon
University it's the largest gift from
outside the united states in the 115
year history of carnegie mellon
university it's the largest gift by TCS
to date to any university and it's the
fifth largest gift in the history of
Carnegie Mellon University
so it is my great pleasure to welcome
mr. Gunther Rajan Chandrasekaran fondly
referred to as Chandra by everybody
who's the CEO and managing director of
Tata Consultancy Services and many
members of his senior leadership team
from across the u.s. and people from
India who have travelled all the way
here and people who work in different
parts of the US TCS is a household name
in many countries it's a household name
in India it's a name that most of the
college to all the college students in
India know about soon college students
in the US will also know about the TCS
name the TCS engagement with carnegie
mellon university also symbolizes
something much grander than dollars and
cents or collaborations or creating
technologies or filing IP or spinning
out companies etc it's a very very
powerful statement about philanthropy
support of higher education in a
borderless world where there is a
relentless competition for talent
whether you are running a university
whether you are running a global company
you want to find the best and the
brightest people to do cutting-edge
things and that partnership brings
together Pittsburgh is the home to
extraordinary philanthropy that goes
back centuries and in a rapidly changing
world that philanthropy also can be seen
around the world and this is an
expression of an engagement by a major
global company in engaging with the
university this gift will enable
Carnegie Mellon University to create
state-of-the-art facilities where
faculty and students will be able to do
cutting-edge research it will become
part and parcel
what we call a corridor where innovation
and creativity along Forbes Avenue will
flourish this is also a place where
there will be opportunities for students
and faculty from Carnegie Mellon
University to come in contact to
interface with and to work with
colleagues from Tata Consultancy
Services in addition to enabling this
facility this gift will also provide
permanent endowment to Carnegie Mellon
University to create and permanently
support TCS presidential fellows and
trees TCS Presidential Scholars
undergraduate and graduate students who
will making it easier to access a highly
cherished carnegie mellon university
education and training this year for the
first time this fall we launched the
presidential fellows and scholars
program for graduate students and
undergraduate students respectively and
we have here with us a group of students
will be the inaugural cohort of
presidential fellows and scholars and I
would like to ask them to please stand
up and be recognized
we have 92 undergraduate students and 50
graduate students who belong to this
initial cohort starting the semester and
it's our aspiration and our goal to
increase this number significantly in
the coming years nothing is more
important to Carnegie Mellon than
attracting nurturing and retaining the
best students the best faculty the best
staff and this gift also enables us to
move further in the right direction so I
would like to take this opportunity to
express my enormous gratitude to Chandra
and the entire team and to the Tata
family of companies and and Tata brand
name in India is very well known and
around the world TCS is a fifteen point
five billion dollar annual revenue
company and half of the revenue comes
from the US and approximately one-tenth
of the revenue comes from India that's
what globalization means it's the market
cap of TCS is eighty billion dollars and
as I mentioned they have clients that
are major corporations around the world
they also have local clients giant eagle
pnc financial services or have been TCS
clients this is not just about a
university partnership Carnegie Mellon
has historically played played a pivotal
role in transforming regional economy
creating new ideas spinning out
companies producing talent it's also
about supporting the city and bringing a
global corporation to Pittsburgh and to
Oakland that's why I'm really delighted
that governor wolf has taken time from
his busy schedule to be here congressman
Doyle Mayor Bill Peduto just arrived and
County Executive rich Fitzgerald and
thank you all for coming Carnegie Mellon
is also known for its ability to
translate be
basic academic research which is deeply
rooted in scholarship pushing the
boundaries of human intellect whether
you are in computer science whether you
are in business where you are in
engineering humanities or social
sciences fine arts Mellon college of
science or Hinds College of Public
Policy and management pushing the
boundaries of human intellect doing
something that that is it not only at
the cutting edge that very few people
can do across disciplinary boundaries
but at the same time taking those
inventions innovations and creative
talents to benefit society on a global
scale bringing in very different issues
to the same problem that creates
economic value that bridges the
significant gulf between the pace at
which technology develops and the pace
at which human condition improves no
other university is as uniquely
positioned to connect pace of advance in
science and technology with the pace at
which we can solve grand challenges that
are facing the humanity in the 21st
century so for that reason as well this
is a significant gift because we can
connect with a company that has the
capacity to engage a significant
fraction of the globe we can also
connect a Carnegie Mellon as a global
university can play a significant role
in taking its talents outside of
Pittsburgh what we envision these kinds
of activities to do would be lead to
significant growth in the region as you
have seen just in the last year we
announced a number of major partnership
with industry there are more nearly 250
to 300 major companies that have come to
carnegie mellon over the last decade two
decades to to work with our faculty and
staff and students we welcome TCS to
this global cohort of companies and it
gives us an opportunity
to take the ideas that the students have
connect them to relevant problems that
face humanity that face business so that
we can eventually not only solve
important problems extract useful value
out of this I want to say a little bit
about my how this came about Chandra and
I come from the same part of India but
we never met each other until about 11
months ago just to add to the point that
this is a global world we live in we met
in China in Tianjin at the summer Davos
at the World Economic Forum and we were
on a panel together last year last
September I invited him to come to
campus to meet with a few colleagues
then we had further discussion and
earlier this year in January we met
again at the world economic forum in
davos in switzerland where we talked
about various ways in which we can
engage and various conversations not
only with him honest with his team but a
number of people on campus led to where
we are today chandra is the CEO and
managing director of tata consultancy
services he is also kindly agreed to
share his time as a member of the
carnegie mellon university presidents
global advisory council which will meet
for the first time on the twenty-second
of October this year he is the chair of
the IT industry World Economic Forum
activities until 2016 in Davos he is
also a member of the indo-us CEO forum
TCS is known as a leader in paying
attention to such things as health and
wellness sustainability and he not only
leads an organization that's been
recognized in Europe in other places as
a much sought after employer Chandra
himself is a very very committed to
health and wellness he ran
marathons fact here and he ran and
completed marathons in Amsterdam New
York mumbai Boston Chicago where else
Pittsburgh next that a lot of heels to
go up and down so it's my great pleasure
to welcome mr. Nader Rajan
Chandrasekaran
Thank You subra for your wonderful
remarks and kind words about TCS it's a
great pleasure and privilege to share
this afternoon with all of you governor
wolf thank you for being here and it
shows the commitment you have towards
education and about technology and about
Carnegie Mellon congressman Doyle thank
you so much mayor Peduto and county
executive Fitz crowd thank you so much
friends CMU faculty students my
colleagues from TCS and ladies and
gentlemen I think we are living in a
world which is undergoing massive
massive transformation we have seen the
economy changing from agricultural
economy to industrial economy to
Internet economy or a century but what
we are seeing now is a transformation to
a new type of economy we can call it by
any number of names you can call it an
innovation economy you can call it a
digital consumer economy you can call it
a economy of data you can call it an
economy of insights I think you will
come up with more and more terms the
biggest difference is this
transformation is happening at a pace
the rapidity that no one is able to
imagine and it's just getting faster and
faster every single day
and we as a large technology company
work with many industries we have a huge
presence with the large companies they
were think about us is a company which
works with the leaders in every other
industry we ourselves or a technology
firm with the right domain knowledge we
make impact in the transformation of
financial services insurance banks
retail companies manufacturing companies
auto companies utility companies lavery
other segments we see this impact
happening across the board every single
form that we work with has one
fundamental question what does this new
economy mean and it's very easy to say
that it is a digital world and it is
very hard to get a consistent definition
of digital if you give a sheet of paper
to everybody in the room and ask them to
write what what you understand about
digital I'm pretty sure you won't have
two answers which is consistent that's
because that's the nature of the beast
there are disruptions happening in every
industry business process of getting
change business models are getting
changed customer experience of getting
changed the very definition of who the
customer is getting changed and that's
the change we are going through but
that's the opportunity and in this world
partnerships are very critical what are
the fundamental technologies that are
making this impact it's the core
computing technologies you can call them
as mobile technologies
social robotics machine learning
creative design analytics industrial
internet internet of things but it is
all happening at a time that all these
technologies are moving at a moving
together at the same time and that's
what makes it very special if these
technologies were to come linearly in a
sequential manner you'll be able to
imagine what we are able to imagine the
fact that these technologies are getting
advanced feeding on to each other is
giving us tremendous possibilities so
it's a company all over focus and all
our investments during the last few
years is to make investments in all
these technologies investments in the
form of research innovation labs
innovation labs for that technological
level or industry level training
recruiting the right talent and
partnering with the ecosystem the
ecosystem maybe startups other
technology companies academic
institutions when we thought about the
possibilities for us it's it was
important to have a very strong
University partnership with the school
which brings an enormous capability
whether it is in terms of research in
terms of
intradermal skills and Carnegie Mellon
is known for the best of Education best
of research in many of these areas
whether it is machine learning
driverless cars robotics any and every
other discipline statistics information
management and how these technologies
can impact businesses and one of the
things I noticed while I visited here
last time is that discipline in the
interface evolving between technology
and every other industry so I am very
very happy and proud that we have this
wonderful partnership developing between
TCS and Carnegie Mellon and subra
mentioned I know him only for less than
a year but we have developed a very good
i would say relationship very good
alignment of thought in terms of what
the possibility is and every time we are
meeting we are talking the fifth step
what is not the next four steps what the
possibilities can be I think it's a
wonderful opportunity Carnegie Mellon
the researchers here the institution
will give a great opportunity for TCS
researchers to do some joint programs we
will bring a lot of Industry problems
and in the future we will have you look
to see some CMU graduates under
graduates joining TCS s
the place to be because we are going to
be focusing on creating a future which
will solve not only solve which will
solve not only the industry problems but
great breakthroughs in solving some of
the societal problems and I want to
thank subra for the amount of effort is
put in to create a vision and every time
I met him I become more impressed with
the amount of homework he does and the
amount of preparation that has gone in
in terms of what he is thinking about
the future I think it's a great
opportunity for both of our institutions
and I look forward to building a
fruitful relationship which will address
multiple facets as we go along thank you
all again for this opportunity and for
being here
thank thank you Chandra some of the
things that Chandra just mentioned not
only capture the physical embodiment of
this gift that you will see as a
physical facility on campus going up in
the next year to a couple of years or so
but also a permanent connection in terms
of supporting students through permanent
endowment which is essentially in
perpetuity for the university this will
also become part and parcel of what we
will see as the evolving vision for the
University physical infrastructure in
the next three to four years we are
poised to see the largest infrastructure
building on this campus in Oakland that
we have seen since the very beginning of
this university in 1900 when Andrew
Carnegie first helped create this
university and this will lead to
enormous benefits for faculty students
teaching spaces work spaces etc on
campus since many of our elected
officials are here I have to say this
will lead to jobs this will lead to
economic development for the city state
and the region so thank you Chandra it
is now my great pleasure to introduce
our governor or governor needs no
introduction to the citizens of
Pennsylvania but I'm going to give a
little introduction that you may not
know about I'm sure you don't know about
I have three common things with the
governor here and I both lived in India
when he was a Peace Corps volunteer in
rural India in Orissa in the late 1960s
when I was a middle school student in
South India we didn't know each other
then
it's connection number one connection
number two here and i got our PhD the
same year from the same institution we
were classmates in 1981 at MIT he in
political science and I enmity in
mechanical engineering we didn't know
each other then we have two degrees we
have degrees from the same another
institution Dartmouth he earned his
degree I did not and some might say I
didn't deserve it in either case the
fact remains that we both have a degree
from there as well and it was a great
pleasure for me to meet him he is one of
those very rare individuals was being a
successful businessman he's a scholar
he's also an elected official doing
public service that combination is quite
remarkable and he twice gave up his
aspirations whether in academia or in
government to go do his family business
so it's an enormous pleasure for me to
introduce governor wolf the governor
wolf I know thank
what he didn't say is that he took about
one third the time I took to get my PhD
so you didn't much better job okay we've
heard a lot of things about very exotic
places Mumbai Davos Tinson Amsterdam you
have finally arrived at the most
cosmopolitan place in the world
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania I don't know
politics just comes naturally to me but
I am really pleased to be part of a very
big announcement and having spent some
time in India I think I probably am one
of the people who know how big a deal
this really is for Pennsylvania for
Pittsburgh for Carnegie Mellon
University what you're kicking off today
is a huge deal for all of us and and
it's really important it reflects well
on the academic caliber of Carnegie
Mellon one of Pennsylvania's one of the
United one of the world's premier
institutions of higher education it
reflects really well on tata consulting
services TCS that they see that you see
such virtue in Carnegie Mellon
personally I think it reflects really
well on Pennsylvania that you see such
great virtue in in our state and I think
it reflects really well on the whole
idea of a partnership between a
university of great university and a
great corporation businesses and
universities can partner together and
really make all our lives better let me
start with Tata on its own Tata
consulting is one of the biggest
companies in the world and it's
certainly one of the largest IT
organizations in the world but it's also
part as subra said it's were also part
of one of the largest and most
prestigious most distinguished
corporations in the world the tata group
of mumbai india now when i served in the
Peace Corps in India tada was of course
known for steel and trucks and so many
more things but I was in a very remote
village in a very remote part of India
but Tata trucks Tata trucks were
everywhere and they were the the quality
Tata as a name I don't think is well
known in the United States but not as
well known as it isn't is in India it is
the premier brand it made a whole range
of great products I was there too early
for software to be part of it but it's
certainly that's part of it Brand
Finance ranks tada as the 39th most
valuable brand in the entire world that
was just a few years ago the brand trust
report ranked it as the third most
trusted brand in 2014 in India just to
give you some example but it's truly an
example of an eternally successful
company because it is eternally
committed to quality in all of its
divisions it's eternally energetic it is
eternally responsive to its customers
and as a result it's eternally growing
so this is a real honor for Pennsylvania
for Tata to have chosen Carnegie Mellon
and Pennsylvania as its partner in
innovation this is a really big deal for
us but it's also a great reflection on
CMU and by the way you know rich
Fitzgerald is a graduate of seeing you
all know that right just wanted to point
that out now I don't want to speak for
Tata but they clearly you clearly see
great virtue and Carnegie Mellon and
you're right to see great virtue in this
remarkable institution of higher
education CMU is well known it has a
well-deserved reputation as a
world-class university right here in
Pittsburgh right here in Pennsylvania
this is especially true in the sciences
it's also true in the social sciences
and humanities of course I say that as
an MIT alumnus but it's true this is a
great institution it stands on its own
as a great Center for Learning was a
great center for discovery a great
center for new ideas and forethought but
CMU has also shown its mettle as a
partner in the extraordinary renaissance
that we see here in Pittsburgh the
energy that is so apparent throughout
pittsburgh has a lot to do with the
brainy and creative people CMU attracts
to this place they have come here from
all over the world literally all over
the world to feast at carnegie mellon's
great academic table they've stayed to
rich enrich this economy our society our
Commonwealth with great ideas great
insights and a great work work ethic
CMU is both a magnet and a catalyst in
that regard it brings together great
people and it encourages them to invest
their considerable skills their
considerable energy right here in
Pittsburgh right here in Pennsylvania in
partnership with great companies like
Tata CMU will do even more to transfer
form this place Pittsburgh is in
Pennsylvania are you aware of that and
of course we're proud of that fact and
CMU is in Pittsburgh which is really
important and enriching Pittsburgh CMU
and Tata will also enrich all of us
everywhere in Pennsylvania and in the
United States and that's as it should be
because Pennsylvania and I'm selling
here Pennsylvania is a remarkable place
with a remarkable heritage now I'm not
sure how many of you are from
Pennsylvania but we're a modest bunch
but just take a moment to think about
the things that we have going for us
this Commonwealth was founded by william
penn on the basis on it really an
extraordinarily innovative idea at that
time on the basis of religious tolerance
freedom of conscience this is where
fittingly this nation got its start with
two constitutions the articles of the
Confederation anybody know where the
articles of the Confederation were
drafted York Pennsylvania okay the
constitution of 1787 Philadelphia
Pennsylvania the Declaration of
Independence which was drafted and
signed in Philadelphia Pennsylvania
which was reaffirmed in blood at the
Battle of Gettysburg Pennsylvania which
was reaffirmed in noble words the
Gettysburg Address by Abraham Lincoln in
gettysburg pennsylvania pennsylvania has
two world-class cities pittsburgh of
course and Philadelphia we have a great
workforce I know that because I build a
business here headquartered in
Pennsylvania and we have a great
location the Keystone State we have a
great size we'd be one of the largest
economies in the entire world if we were
an independent nation that's
Pennsylvania and of course we have some
of the finest natural beauty in the
world I mean I Love New England but if
you go across route 6 northern
Pennsylvania there's nothing prettier
than that in the world
so this partnership between Carnegie
Mellon and Tata makes great sense in no
small part because it takes place right
here in Pennsylvania a place where
innovation big ideas and grand
achievements are integral to who we
really are as modest as we are we are
really great finally finally yes we are
thank you I was bucking for a standing
ovation but that's all right that's okay
it's not bad so the spirit of innovation
I think is really important the fourth
thing and final thing that I think is
important about this partnership is it
shows what we can do when a world-class
company and a world-class university
partner up this is going to be really
amazing for this place the spirit of
innovation we so rightly attribute to
the market to the free market is
actually magnified by this kind of
marriage creativity and originality are
at the heart of the carnegie mellon
university's culture and tada has shown
itself to be a world leader in
converting customer needs into practical
products and services itself very
innovative and creative job they do that
by working together I think these two
organizations will produce new ideas
that will address challenges that matter
to real people and real companies in the
real world and as that happens in
Pittsburgh and Pennsylvania this will
continue to make us an innovative hub
that we were in the past and will
continue to be in the future the source
of ideas and products and services that
will transform as it has in the past
transform the world so I want to say
congratulations to Tata congratulations
to CMU on this great new partnership
we've always been proud to count both
CMU and Tata consulting services as
members of the Pennsylvania family this
is great this great new partnership
makes both even more significant members
of that family you're both significant
members already but even more so after
this great partnership takes off and it
makes our family even stronger and
better the family of Pennsylvania so
thanks to CMU for attracting such an
eminent partner to Pittsburgh and
thank you to Tata for being so
attractive and so willing to be
attracted to a place like Pittsburgh and
CMU thank you very much and
congratulations
thank you it's it's my pleasure now to
introduce congressman mike doyle
congressman doyle represents the 14th
congressional district that includes
where we are the two short years that
I've been here I come to appreciate the
congressman's warmth friendship not just
here but also I had a chance to see him
in other places in other events and he
made CMU very proud including our
faculty member Raj Raj Kumar when he
drove in our driverless car and they
caught a lot of national attention he
serves in the house congressional
robotics caucus where he's been a
champion for Carnegie Mellon University
for science and technology for research
funding and is so accessible to all of
us here it's my great pleasure and
privilege to introduce congressman and
was also my good friend Mike Doyle
you know I was just going to tell the
governor when he was trying to get that
standing ovation Jim roar and I looked
at each other and said he's about 35
million short well what a pleasure to be
here today what a great day this is for
for Pittsburgh in the entire region I'm
so happy to be here at the invitation of
my good friend Sri president Surrey Shin
to join in the announcing of this this
partnership between TCS and Carnegie
Mellon University I mean this is an
initiative that's bringing together two
powerhouses of innovation from opposite
sides of the globe the establishment of
this Center can help accelerate the
development and adoption of autonomous
systems technologies to transform the
way we live and to benefit the global
economy the announcement of this
partnership is a very welcome
development for our city it represents
another important step in our region's
transformation from a center of 20 20th
century manufacturing to a leader in
21st century technological innovation I
believe that TCS has made a wise choice
in selecting Carnegie Mellon and the
city of Pittsburgh for this partnership
and I want to compliment you for
recognizing the critical mass of
ingenuity an intellectual capital we
have here in southwestern Pennsylvania
and I want to commend you and express
our appreciation for you adding to it
Pittsburgh's academic institutions
attract the best and brightest faculty
and students from around the world to
study and live here including a number
from India we would not be a center of
academic and medical excellence today
without the influx of this international
brainpower all of that brain power and
energy concentrated in one place
produces remarkable innovation CMU for
example generates more startups than any
other major research university in
America for each federal research
dollars spent there and many of those
startups have been in robotics
artificial intelligence and advanced
information technologies Pittsburgh and
the United States have long valued our
strategic and economic partnerships with
India the CMU TCS partnership announced
here today will serve to further
strengthen those ties to our mutual
benefit I want to extend a warm welcome
to Chandra and the leadership at TCS and
thank you for traveling here today to
join us for this announcement I want to
congratulate my friend subra for his
excellent leadership and for once again
contributing to Pittsburgh's growth as
an internationally recognized leader in
innovation and transformative technology